you've probably been hearing about
Argentina and the suspicious death of a
federal prosecutor who had accused the
president of covering up Iran's role in
a terrorist attack in the country if not
watch our piece on it to get up to speed
because there's much more to this murder
mystery I spoke with Ernesto Simon a
history professor at the University of
Richmond to see what else was going on
just below the surface well I think that
in order to understand our will happen
in general 18 wonder when the federal
prosecutor was killed was found dead we
had to understand the 24 years of an
investigation of the terrorist attacks
on 90 94 the most important terrorist
attacks in Energy Tank history in which
due to the last 22 during the previous
22 years there had been no advances in
the investigation no advances until 2013
when Argentina decided to do something
different it signed a memorandum of
understanding with Iran agreeing to set
up a truth commission around the bombing
simon says it was a bold diplomatic move
that angered the intelligence community
did the argentine government speak with
the u.s. embassy about creating this
memorandum of understanding with iran
before it went ahead and did it know
that we have any information about it no
nice man worked closely with the US
Embassy on the investigation pursuing
another route with Iran could have been
seen as a slap in the face plus
countries the deal directly with Iran
usually don't fall in Uncle Sam's good
favor as everybody 80 guests but then
got to know through their WikiLeaks was
heavily invested in pursuing the same
line of investigation of the previous 22
years that had led nowhere that was
basically blame in Iran and basically
not doing that much more I'm not saying
that Iran was not responsible I have no
idea but at that moment both Israel and
the u.s. were particularly interested in
blaming Iran and particularly interested
in not blame in Syria which was your
suspect and then at that time was a very
close ally of the u.s. in the world this
is a huge accusation that nice man was
about to present against the president
and top officials
do you think it holds any water is
extremely way is surprisingly
unsubstantiated it doesn't look like
something written by a lawyer let alone
a prosecutor you never try to give
impunity to the Iranian the five people
from around the world accusatory attacks
it doesn't make sense of the of oil
Argentina does not need that much oil
and there's nothing particularly that
the kind of oil that Iran produced our
Nestor says direct diplomacy with Iran
is now impossible for Argentina and he
thinks that diplomacy is key to getting
to the bottom of the bombing another day
another angle on this whole thing geez
is the truth out there the president has
pointed a finger at Argentina's
notorious spy agency seated she thinks
they're the ones targeting her I mean
when I go to your Mac